Oh
Oh
something that you want to keep in mind
that might not be apparent to you upon
first reading of Renee de cartes
discourse on method same thing would go
for his meditations too by the way is
that he is actually a master storyteller
he is a great philosopher and he's
putting together some really brilliant
ideas and exploring some new paths in
metaphysics even in morals but he's
framing them within a narrative
structure and it's worth spending a
little bit of time looking at how that's
supposed to work what's going on in the
text and that's not being unfit Ithaca
it's actually you might say a
prerequisite to fully understand the
philosophical import about what's going
on so if we wanted to say what kind of
story is being told here it's a quest
it's a narrative about seeking something
that isn't necessarily lost from the
beginning but it certainly isn't possess
something that is yet to be found and
it's a quest for for knowledge it's an
epistemological quest we can say it's an
epistemological inquiry quest is better
because it gives us the sense that looks
somebody's actually throwing themselves
into it I'm just sitting back in there
armchair as the current himself is going
to derive you know speculating about
this sort of stuff he's engaged in a
practical process and he wants knowledge
he wants to possess certainty he wants
to be secure in saying that the
knowledge that he possesses is really
knowledge he'll talk a little bit later
about what exactly is his greatest
desire was in part one he says I always
get an extreme desire to learn to
distinguish the true from the false
being able to distinguish the true from
the false that's what knowledge in large
part consists in being
to say that's right that's wrong this
person over here doesn't know what
they're talking about this person over
here doesn't know what they're talking
about but why in order to see clearly in
my actions and proceed with confidence
in this life so it's not a merely
speculative armchair exercise that he's
carrying out this is something that's
supposed to pertain to a person's entire
what we might call human condition
they're their own way of living out the
universal human condition that brings us
to another important point who's the
main character of this it's what we
might call an everyman an ordinary
person they cart himself who is far from
an ordinary person is going to put on
the persona or put on the mask of being
the average Joe or if you like the
average Josephine right being just a
rational human being like anybody else
now why is he doing that we'll come back
to that moment we'll come back to that
in a moment let's look at how he does
that first so he says this is in the
beginning of part 1 there's a power of
judging well and distinguishing what is
true from what is false that's good
sense or reason and that's naturally
equal in all people everybody possesses
it to some degree actually the same
degree but do they use it to the same
extent that's the the key distinguisher
there so he says the diversity of our
opinions doesn't arise because some
people are more reasonable than others
everybody's just as reasonable as
anybody else the question is whether
they use that Faculty of reason properly
whether they use their mind the way that
they ought to that's part of what the
discourse is going to be teaching us
about is how one ought to use their mind
so when they Kurt tells us later on that
oh I'm not prescribing rules for
everybody I'm just telling you how it
worked for me there's a little bit of
cover-up going on there he's being what
we call disingenuous he's not really
just trying to tell us his own store
he's trying to tell us the story about
how anybody who has got something on the
ball and doesn't have some terrible
impediments can arrive at certainty and
truth so he says the only thing that
makes us different than distinguishes us
from the animals is what distinguishes
all of us from the animals and it
distinguishes us equally that is the
Faculty of reason it's entirely complete
in each person so we're on the same
level ground as far as Descartes in the
story is concerned so easy to say look
this is what I could do you could be
doing the same thing as well he tells us
that he doesn't feel himself to be
extraordinary my mind was not more
perfect than the ordinary mind there's a
lot of people smarter than me whose
thoughts are quicker whose imagination
is clear clear and distinct whose
memories is you know more well stocked
with experiences so why is he doing that
why is he concealing from us the fact
that he really is a genius well there's
a rhetorical force in saying this sort
of thing and you see it in infomercials
you see it when people say this scheme
worked for me and it can work for you
just as well now purchase it accepting
carts not trying to get anybody to buy
anything he is trying to offer something
to them which he thinks is actually
going to make their life better but she
thinks is going to allow them to get
away from illusions from doubts from
uncertainties and finally attain true
knowledge about things not only about
you know speculative or theoretical
matters but about how we ought to run
our own lives so it works instead of him
sort of preaching from above down to us
he's saying let's go along on this
journey so let's see how it actually
works out for him he begins by talking
about his education which he he
summarizes
by saying it was an education of books
meaning that books were used as the
primary repository of knowledge and the
the work of the instructor was to
comment on the tax to lead the students
through it to get them to imbibe and
assimilate the knowledge that was
provided to them within the texts and
these are all the subjects that he in
fact studied as a student in this Jesuit
school of the hop when he was a kid and
also in the University he goes on any
studies law in the University and
studies a lot of other things too on the
way he doesn't find this to be
satisfactory and we'll talk about why it
will look at why in just a moment so he
does something quite reasonable he says
well if the truth the certainty the
knowledge that I wanted wasn't there in
books where else can I look for it now
there's two places that make good sense
examining himself and looking at what he
calls the book of the world no this is
not a new concept that he comes up with
it is it's a trope that had been around
for quite a while but the idea is you
can travel you know Bourque's are like
traveling back in time or traveling to
other cultures he says it's like a
conversation with the best minds that we
have available you know you read
Aristotle you're having a conversation
with aerosol if you're doing your job as
a reader when you're reading a car you
should be having a conversation with
Descartes not just sort of passively
just letting the letters hit you and
saying oh yes whatever he says but
there's something lacking there they're
not really our contemporaries if we go
around in the world that we live in we
might be able to learn a lot more we can
also turn inward and examine ourselves
we can pay attention to what works for
us where we make stupid mistakes what
went on when we made a stupid mistake
how we can avoid making it again all
that is going beyond what we're going to
get out of books
that's not going to satisfy it either
and he's going to move on to something
else after that but that's in the other
parts and we'll get to that in a moment
let's come back now to looking at his
his book learn his educational his
pedagogical process and he tells us that
he was nourished on literature from the
time of his childhood why well because
people persuaded him that through
literature one could acquire a clear and
assured understanding of everything
useful in life now isn't that similar to
what we tell people about going to
college today go to college after you
after you do that things will fall into
place and you have a good job and you'll
be able to understand what's going on
now like those uneducated ignorant
people over there it's kind of
interesting because there's a lot of
people who have a lot better sense than
those who have gone to college because
they spend some time working in the
world and learn something about human
nature in the process but we do sell
this line to a lot of people look if you
just study this this stuff you'll
eventually figure it all out it'll make
sense to you there's an implicit promise
like that in our own time with these
websites like say Wikipedia I'm not
knocking Wikipedia you know it's a
useful source for some things but it
shouldn't be your go-to for everything
it shouldn't substitute for your brain
it shouldn't be the memory system that
you rely upon in part because you know
there's all sorts of problems with how
it's edited the articles are in fact
getting better but there's still errors
in some of them and unless you actually
know the subject material you don't know
where the errors are but they Kirk is in
a position where a lot of people are you
know the encyclopedia has what I want
the library has what i want my teachers
have what i want i can go to a book
which is put together by somebody smart
after all and if I just
that well enough and learn that that
that discipline learn that science
that's being taught in that book well
enough I will actually have mastered
something that's useful for me now I do
need to say something about this word
science over here that we're seeing use
the science we're used to thinking of
the sciences in terms of physics
chemistry you know biology what we call
the Natural Sciences or computer science
or in terms of applied things like
engineering or in terms of what we call
the neck the the social sciences and
French they're called the human sciences
in German they're called the mental or
spiritual sciences the guys to this and
Shafton like sociology and psychology
and anthropology and we don't normally
think of something like philosophy or
theology or literature as being a
science well that's because the word
science has a broader reference in dick
Harte it means a systematic body of
knowledge that is organized that can
provide us with the answers to what what
it is that we need to know so we could
add in here things like computer
sciences or mechanics that he talks
about as well but these are all what he
is willing to call sciences so you've
got to do a little bit of adaptation of
your mind if you're if you're really
stuck in the a model of the term science
that we use today in the
english-speaking world that's just sort
of a side note now he talks about having
been educated in all of these and they
all provide us with them with something
but they don't provide us with is
knowledge so let's look look first at
what he says that they do provide us
with he says I was in one of the most
famous schools in Europe they were
erinite people who are teaching me I
learned everything which the others
learned there and I even went out and
read other books so I really ran through
the entire gamut of what was available
what did I learn so literature or
language
I knew that the languages one learns
there are necessary for the
understanding of ancient books okay so
if you want to be able to read Sophocles
in the Greek you got to read Greek if
you want to be able to read de coeur in
the original Latin you got to read Latin
right if you want to read a card in
French you got to read French the
languages are good to know not just so
you can go find the bathroom or order at
a restaurant but so you can open up the
world of literature because you know
they're couldn't quite often be a lot
lost in the translation and unless you
know the language you can't tell what's
been lost what is literature provide us
with he talks about fables so he says
fables the gracefulness of them awakens
the intellect the memorable actions of
history raise the mind and if one reads
with discretion help to form ones
judgment so you know if we're reading
say history of World War two and reading
about Patton i'm not a huge admirer of
patent but you know there's some things
about him that i that i did--like and
you could draw from his example things
you know i should do this and maybe i
shouldn't do this don't slap soldiers
who have shell shock or something like
that so you're deriving some sort of
benefit from it and this is where he
says that reading these books is like
having a conversation with the greatest
minds that are available eloquence or
rhetoric is an incomparable power and
beauty that is the ability to use
language you think about speech writing
for example or if you had to take a
speech class that's what rhetoric is
learning how to speak well or if you go
to Toastmasters right that's also the
same sort of thing poetry has a most
ravishing delicacy and softness not the
most enticing recommendation there but
what he's talking about is is reading
literary works if you've ever read a
book and you've been captivated by the
language of it that's what he's talking
about in terms of poetry as a matter of
fact if you've ever been listening to a
song and such as an earworm
but it's really meaningful to you and it
allows you to sort of you know figure
out how you ought to approach things or
how do you ought to think about things
or even to anticipate things that would
fall under what he's talking about his
poetry so all those are nice but notice
none of those have provided knowledge
what about these things mathematics
moral theology philosophy he says um
mathematics has very skillful inventions
which can go a long way to satisfying
the curious as well as facilitating all
the arts and lessening the work of men
that's an interesting way to talk about
mathematics isn't it when you had to
study math in K through 12 and you got
kind of bored with it as I did and your
teacher would say this is going to be
useful for you someday you may have
thought about well sure I'll balance my
checkbook or something like that the
card is talking about things that go way
way beyond that and if you proceed far
enough into mathematics it actually has
a certain kind of beauty and elegance of
its own that can be extremely appealing
what about study of morals or ethics
that that can also be useful as well the
writings which deal with morals contain
several lessons and a number of
exhortation to virtue which are
extremely useful so you no morals is
good for telling us sheep up don't be a
bad person you could think about for
example Google with their don't be evil
motto that's you know what he's talking
about is as morals theology what does
that teach us how to get to heaven isn't
that isn't that nice philosophy provides
a way of speaking plausibly on all
matters and making oneself admired by
those who are less scholarly notice he
doesn't say philosophy provides you with
truth he says philosophy lets you talk
about all sorts of things and people who
don't really know any better people who
are you know as well informed as you are
will probably think that you know what
you're talking about now that is not a
recommendation of philosophy as
Descartes
has encountered it into his own time
when he talks about some other arts as
well jurisprudence its law medicine
these all bring honor and riches to
those who cultivate them notice again
none of these have actually provided us
with what we can call reliable certain
knowledge they've all provided us with
other types of goods but not the good of
truth not the good of certainty not the
good of knowledge Descartes says it's
good to have examined all of them in
order to know their legitimate value in
to guard against being wrong now let's
talk about what problems they have so he
says literature like fables for example
they make us imagine several totally
impossible events as possible so if for
example we're reading Greek plays or
we're looking at what else would fall
under this we're thinking about you know
stories that are told fiction we're
going to be sort of deforming our minds
according to Descartes so that we think
the things that aren't really the case
are the way that that things turn out to
be in in real life imagine if you were
nourished on a diet only of action
movies so you thought that the way to
solve things you punch people in the
face never talk real tough to them well
that's not going to that's not going to
get you very far and that sort of thing
can work in the movies but it doesn't
really work in real life romance movies
great example to you know imagine if
you're in your life your dating life
according to the romance movies that are
out there probably get thrown in prison
for being a stalker with some of them so
literature is really not going to give
us what we want and it's it's kind of
leading us astray even history Descartes
says history's pretty good because at
least they stick to what what actually
happened but they leave things out so he
says even if they don't change or
increase the importance of things they
admit the most menial and less
admirable circumstances so what is left
is not to pick the truth history is
already a kind of editing that's going
on so history doesn't really provide us
with the truth either what about poetry
and rhetoric he says I place great value
on eloquence I was in love with poetry
but I thought that they were gifts given
to the mind rather than fruits of study
so what did card is saying is that these
are not things you can really teach a
person they're just sort of like skills
that some people have and other people
don't some people have the genius for
them other people don't and so you can't
really teach somebody how to become a
good poet you can't even teach somebody
how to be a good order they either are
or they aren't and there's not much that
you can do one way or or the other so
that's not going to provide us with
knowledge what about mathematics this is
going to be an important one for
Descartes because mathematics provides
him with a model of what really is clear
and distinct knowledge he says I found
it delightful because the certainty and
clarity of its reason I didn't yet
notice it's true use its true use is
going to get rolled into philosophy and
come out of it so he says I thought it
was just useful for mechanical arts you
know making technology making things
that would work for us you know thinking
about how to make artifacts like this
chalkboard and a current really did go
quite far with mathematics you have to
remember he invented Cartesian
coordinates then he talks about morality
morals ethics and he says that the ain't
the writings of the ancient pagans that
deal with morality are like superb and
magnificent palaces built on nothing but
sand and mud they don't actually have a
foundation they talk about virtue but
they don't really know what it is and if
they don't know what it is they might
actually be doing something that's more
harmful than helpful theology um that's
beyond me Descartes says and this is
sort of a way of seeming to place it
above himself but at the same
time putting it at a distance and saying
yeah you know I don't know about this
God stuff you know that's that's beyond
me that's that's supernatural I'm just
going to stick with what i can actually
no because you know I'm just an ordinary
guy you priests are you ministers you do
what you like with that and you know get
back to me in the end when you've got
the answers about that that's a good way
of saying I'm not going to have anything
to do with you guys this is not going to
be what I'm going to focus on what about
philosophy so here he says two really
important things to us what is that
philosophy he says it's been cultivated
for several centuries by the most
excellent minds that had ever lived but
there is still nothing in it that was
not disputed and which was thus not
still in doubt so if there are more than
one available philosophical positions
that reasonable people can take the card
is saying that's a sign that philosophy
is not really at the level of a science
yet if it had attained true knowledge
certainty then there really only would
be one philosophy available all the
other ones would be wrong and you'd say
look don't bother with that stuff here's
the the one philosophy that's true since
we're not at that point we can't say
that philosophy can actually provide us
with knowledge here's why that's a
problem this is point number two all
these other disciplines insofar as they
are scientific guess what they depend on
philosophy now why is that I mean you
might say I've never studied philosophy
in my life and I've been studying this
field you know social work or you know
psychology or business or pick whatever
you like for you know four years in
college as is the first philosophy class
I'm going to take why would you say that
anything is based on philosophy well
because if
you actually take any discipline and you
look at its foundations first of all
historically many of these other
disciplines actually came out of
philosophy all the Natural Sciences
originally were called natural
philosophy they still worried in Indyk
Hartstein mathematics has a sort of semi
independent status medicine is a
semi-independent stance but there's a
lot of blending together in ancient
times already between those and most of
the ologies that you can run across came
out of philosophy historically at one
point and you might say well you know
they left behind that philosophical
mumbo jumbo stuff and now they're truly
scientific well when you get to their
foundational concepts quite often you're
no longer doing that discipline you're
doing philosophy so sociology for
example how do you know that the
concepts that you're working with really
correspond to something out there in the
world that's not a sociological question
that's an epistemological question
that's a question of philosophy how
should you behave as a professional in
your field that's a question in ethics
that's a question in philosophy what is
your feel really working with what is
the subject matter when you get down to
it that's a metaphysical question that's
philosophy so the curt is calling our
attention the fact that if philosophy
hasn't got its house in order that's a
problem for all the other disciplines
they can go on doing what they do but
they've just been lucky so far they
haven't they're working in the realm of
opinion not the realm of true knowledge
so it becomes a key project to get this
philosophy stuff right if we can't get
it from the books we can't get it from
previous education where are we going to
get it so here's where we go on and date
card says I'm going to look at other
sources I'm going to look inside myself
look into the great book of the world
I'm going to travel around I'm going to
get some
practical experience and what does he do
he doesn't just want her around and look
at stuff he thinks about it he reflects
on he tests himself according to those
things so he says it seemed to me I
could arrive at more truth in reasoning
in the reasoning each man makes
concerning the matters that are
important to him and in which events
could punish him soon afterwards if you
judge badly then the reasoning man made
by a man of letters in his study so
Descartes says I'm going to go and
travel the world then he does so he
becomes a mercenary he doesn't do much
fighting actually but he travels around
and he's constantly observing people he
says I observed courts and people's and
events and what did I realize says I
examined the customs of other people I
found as much diversity among them as
among the opinions of the Philosopher's
so could I learn anything from that sure
I could learn something don't trust any
of those customs because they're not
going to provide you with knowledge you
know think about this how do we know if
Americans that the American Way whatever
that means is actually the right way or
that our perspective is the right
perspective should we be concerned about
the American dream should we take the
Constitution whether we're understanding
that in a conservative way or a liberal
way both of which are actually
deformations of it as you know some sort
of document for how we want to live well
what evidence do we have for those
things what grounding what foundation do
we have for thinking that the customs
that comprise our way of life is the
best one the necessary one if we're
Cartesian about this what we would study
abroad and then we would come back and
we'd say you know the French do things
this way the tanzanians do things this
way the Vietnamese do things this way
and then we'd actually be smart enough
to say well and parts of France and do
it this way other parts they do it this
way and parts of Vietnam they do it this
way other parts
that way we recognized university there
and we would say our only way of looking
at things is circumscribed and is not
therefore to be trusted as certain
knowledge so he says I learned not to
believe too firmly in anything which I
had been persuaded to believe merely by
example and custom so i freed myself of
errors and I allowed myself to be open
to something else notice at this point
he doesn't have knowledge the question
is after I do that what is going to
provide me with knowledge and you might
say so far it's all been negative but
it's not just negative if you don't
actually try out what it is an education
can offer you if for example you were
just going to say well you know Rene
Descartes pulled me that I don't have to
actually read any books because look it
didn't help him out that would not be a
smart way to go they card is saying try
these out see how far they can get you
but you're not going to find that they
actually provide you with certainty and
then go around in the world try that out
see if you can find certainty by looking
at yourself by looking at the world and
after that hasn't worked for you now
you're ready to move on to something
that might actually yield you the thing
that you desire knowledge